hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today it's gonna
be a historical game review going over a
game between Bogoliubov and Alekhine way
back in 1922 apologies if I butchered
either of those names you're gonna have
to deal with it this is a game which was
a very very interesting one and there
are some fun tactics and some fun
positional play as well so why don't we
just jump in here and see what happened
d 4 F 5 the Dutch so already I'm rooting
against Alekhine here but what can you
do sometimes you make a mistake on move
1 c4 Knight f6 g3e 6 Bishop g2 Alekhine
gives this check not the most common
line these days but a fairly well
respected one Bishop d2 and Alec n goes
ahead and gets rid of these bishops and
this is an idea you see in a lot of
openings actually this Bishop b4 check
the point is sometimes it forces white
to miss places pieces for example listen
it coming to d2 means this Knight isn't
coming to c3 even if it gets there with
tempo and c3 is generally a better
square on d2 it also kind of blocks in
this Queen and so this is usually the
idea this Bishop b4 a check which looks
a little bit unnatural sometimes now
that being said black continues
developing then they c6 Knight gf3
castles castles and now d6
Queen b3 King h8 Queen c3 and the point
of this kind of a natural maneuver with
the Queen bringing it out to c3 is well
for one the knight was in the way
so we've solved that problem and
secondly most of blacks ideas result
revolve around pushing this pawn forward
to e5 and expanding in the center trying
to make use of this F pawn by
controlling more of these central
squares along the e-file however do
despite all of White's best efforts he
did not manage to stop black from
playing the move e5 of course you can
capture this pawn but if
recaptures and you try to take it you
run into a very nasty problem on the D 2
square so II five works out tactically
so white simply responds with III
defending his Center as well black
continues with this move
a5 hinting at the fact that you might
want to place the knight on to this B 4
square at a later date
note that this Knight actually works
pretty well in tandem with this Dutch
structure because black may push to e4
and from E for the night and the pawn
together control the d3 square and that
can sometimes become an annoying outpost
the move b3 is played for white now it'd
be a mistake to play Knight before here
because a3 would simply kick your night
away in addition to the fact that you
blundered your pawn I forgive you it's
ok
instead we see queenie 8 defending the
pawn a3 is played by white before this
night even thinks about landing on b4
and here black plays Queen h5 which is
you know a little ambitious I think much
better for black for Alekhine here is
actually just to play the movie for just
take your central space and don't look
back
this night is gonna have to be a little
bit misplaced no matter where you go you
come to e1 then you had to go to e1 if
you come to g5 you might get kicked by n
h6 move and if you're not careful
Black's gonna start rollin over rollin
over your kings side with all of this
space instead though Queen h5 alack I
wanted to get the Queen into play and
here white plays an interesting move
h4 the point being he wants to control
this g5 square a little bit better and
this h4 move can be pretty helpful here
actually of course in that last line we
just looked at h6 followed by g5 was a
very relevant idea for black and so this
move is a little bit aimed at preventing
that
that being said black continues with
this move Knight g4 keeping a closer eye
on the central pawn white continues with
Knight g5 perhaps aiming for a similar
idea we
bringing this pawn to e6 that we looked
at like bringing this knight to d3 both
very very annoying squares black simply
plays this move Bishop d7 which is a
little bit strange to my eyes I think
it's much better to just solve the
problem of this Knight immediately bring
this knight back to h3 where it's not
going to do you any harm
but okay Bishop d7 not the worst move
ever and now white really needed to
continue expanding on the Queen's side
you know you blacks advantage kind of
lies on the Kings side which you can see
is where he's placed all of his pieces
and so White's play should really be
focused more around the Queen side moves
like beef or moves like b5 really aiming
to open up this Bishop instead though
white got a little bit sidetracked here
and this Knight was putting some
uncomfortable pressure on a lot of these
squares in the black or in the white
camp it was like f4 could come on the
board so white played this move f3
forcing this night away and this is
actually a big downside to this H form
of if you see black has this option to
play h6 whereas white no longer has the
option to play h3 so he resorts to f3 to
kick this night away and if there's a
very very weakening move here this night
simply retreats to f6 and now the point
of whites play was to continue with f4
and this idea is just a little bit
misguided by giving up so many central
squares with this full dark square
commitment black solution is actually
going to be quite nice here
the movie 4 comes and you'll hear a lot
of people give give the Dutch a little
bit of a hard time because you usually
end up with you know the Dutch bishop
where it's stuck behind all these pawns
on light squares but the fact is this
Bishop isn't doing much better either
just because you know it's an opponent's
pawn on this light square doesn't mean
this bishop has a better future than
than this bishop and so this position
while white technically has the good
bishop and black has the bad bishop it's
actually black's bishop that turns out
to be more useful supporting these
squares on the Queen side while the
white bishop is locked away on g2
and so because of that I really don't
like the way that that white chose to
play this with that in mind though white
continues with the move Rick f.2d one
and the move aged six comes finally
kicking this night away we see night
aged three and now black continues with
d5 completing his expansion in the
center white tries a very strange
rerouting of this night to the f1 square
supporting the center a little bit we
see Knight isse Evan from black and now
white plays this move a four and so a
four is a pretty bad move actually you
see black reroute this night away from
the be four square but just because it
moved away doesn't mean it can't come
back and Alekhine does the the funniest
thing and also the best thing which is
directly after playing Knight d7 once he
sees this move a four he comes right
back this Knight comes back to c6 and
this B Foursquare is a permanent
weakness now for white much better than
a four I think is to you know really try
to expand a little bit with this with
this b4 idea keeping keeping in mind all
those ideas you want to expand on the
queenside with white although this
position is already a little bit shaky
instead though we see a for this night
comes back to c6 and after rook d2 black
wastes no time coming to b4 and this
idea that i talked about all those moves
ago finally comes into play
this Knight is aiming for the d3 square
and it's going to be a permanent problem
for for white we see Bishop h1 for white
which is a disgusting move never play
Bishop h1 in a position like this where
this diagonals forever closed I guess
the idea is he wanted to bring some
pieces over to this Kings side to try
and open things up on this side of the
board but this is just just not a good
idea it's just a bad idea isn't it we
see Queenie eight supporting some
pressure on this Queen side even more
preparing some ideas like maybe
expanding we see rook g2 from white the
point of Bishop h1 now after D takes c4
if
the Queen where to capture this pawn
simply Bishop e6 and this pawn is
looking a little bit weak and you can
imagine things like ninety five things
like c5 are going to come so instead
white just ops to play pawn takes c4
controlling these squares a little bit
better but of course this gives up this
pawn on a4 and now black is simply doing
very very well
this Knight comes back to f2 really
trying to force through this move g4 to
try and loosen this diagonal just a bit
but it's it's far too slow this Bishop
retreats to d7 this Knight comes to d2
now like I said really trying to hammer
home the pressure on this pawn but now
white plays our black plays a nice move
b5 like I said expanding on the Queen
side now that he has this material an
advantage in this and it comes to d1 and
finally this night lands on the annoying
d3 square I told you it would happen if
you didn't believe me a shame on you
knights and pawns together work very
very well you might be thinking well
hang on a second
did you just hang upon and the answer is
maybe black plays this move before and
after it takes 8 I'll let you calculate
to the end of the line I'm sure you all
can do it at home as you may have
noticed your queen is attacked and so
you might be attempted to recapture the
rook but not if your Alekhine here if
your alekan you do something a little
bit fancier so I'll let you at home try
and pause the video try and find the
full line to see the path to victory
here ok good luck if you found it I
don't believe you you might have found
the first move B takes c3 and after rook
takes e8 maybe you didn't see anything
better than recapturing this rook but
the problem if you do that of course
that white will simply take this pawn so
you have to do better
how do you do better well you go and
make a new queen that's pretty good c2
is actually a fork
not the most common fork you'll ever see
in chess
this pawn is actually forking to
promotion squares it's impossible to
stop both play Knight b3 to stop this
one or you could play you know any
Knight move to stop this one but you
can't stop both at the same time you can
however take this rook for free which he
does but after King h7 the same problem
remains in the game white shows Knight
f2y it goes ahead and makes a second
Queen and this Knight comes back to f1
but now this is a rather unfortunate
configuration of of all the white pieces
here it's very clear to see this Bishop
is not in the game this rook is also
pretty much completely out of the game
and after Knight II 1 if white plays a
funny move there's actually a very nice
checkmate here to look out for of course
why didn't allow it play trick h2
defending the f3 square but now I have
to remove like Queen c4 these pieces
just aren't in the game and it's clear
to see the black is winning rook b8 was
White's choice now Bishop b5 makes
another checkmating threat if you play a
move like Knight d2 you're gonna run
into moves like Queen c1 moves like
Queen e2 and it's it's just checkmate is
near so white sacrifices his only active
piece to get rid of this bishop and now
g4 White's big idea finally comes onto
the board to little fanfare simply
Knight f3 Czech Bishop takes pawn takes
pawn takes at 5c Queen e2 we see d5 and
while this is a lot of pawns for white
keep in mind
none of his pieces are in the game
they're all serving a purely defensive
role so black simply plays King g8
really taking his time even repeating
the position well not repeating the
position but going back and forth after
E for Knight takes e4 94 queenie for
simply a queen for a rook and a night
but the rook and the knight are nowhere
near active and it's it's a fairly
simple one for for alekhine here d6 C
takes D 6 f6 all the pawns fall off the
board
we finally see York t2 and now after
Queenie two black sacrifices his second
Queen for the match sacrificing actually
all four of his major pieces not
something you see every day and after he
takes f1 his third Queen has been
sacrificed for a winning King and pawn
endgame which was quickly decided after
a few more moves King e6 king e4 d5
check and here white resigns so if you
want to play like alekhine is very very
difficult he managed to sacrifice five
major pieces of this game starting the
game with only three very impressive
stuff
the takeaway I would take the takeaway I
would take away from this game is to
stick stick to your plan stick to the
natural plan so I should have been
expanding on the Queen side rather than
you know conglomerating all of his
pieces around his King and that's really
where Alekhine broke through once white
started committing to this this awkward
plan on the Kings side that's when
Alekhine got his advantage with that in
mind thank you so much for joining me
for this episode my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you in the next episode